YouTuber Shazad Sheikh aka the brown car
guy drives a modern classic BMW he'll
now have to pay 16 a day for the ultra
low emission or Euless charge the
scheme's good news for air pollution but
it's bad news for car enthusiasts we're
in the middle of a cost of living crisis
people are
people are completely unjustified
especially because the time scale was so
short we're talking less than 12 months
nine out of 10 vehicles on London's
roads are already compliant and the
London mayor is offering eight thousand
eight hundred dollars to drivers who
scrap their Vans and two and a half
thousand for cars but shazard wouldn't
dream of ditching his pride and joy
for others such as plasterer Pat Smith
the extra cost of running his van puts a
strain on his business what's really
frustrating about it is that we're all
going to be getting insults in a bit
when we've uh
got perfectly good Vans to drive
I've passed a bill onto the customer
or I've got just a swallow it myself
the
science is clear previous lower emission
zones in Central and inner London cut
harmful pollutants drastically
after today five million more londoners
will be breathing clean air I've been
quite clear from the outset the decision
to expand the U.S was a difficult one
but it's a vital one it's the right
thing to do the new expansion covers
1500 square kilometers and nearly 700
000 liable cars making it the largest
low emission Zone in the world there is
absolutely no doubt amongst scientists
amongst health professionals and amongst
people who experience this every day
that air pollution is having a
devastating effect on our health if we
look at the impact of the original
Euless there is clear data that there
was massive improvements in health
well they may have brought their anger
all the way to the gates of down the
street but there's actually very little
that the government can do to overturn
Euless given that England's High Court
recently ruled that all the work that
went into making the scheme was thorough
and legally sound the Conservative Party
candidate
13 965.
the issues also become massively
politicized after a recent election in
former prime minister Boris Johnson's
old seat of Uxbridge the opposition
labor party had been expected to seize
the constituency easily from the ruling
conservatives who instead punished for
the labor London mayor's plans a year
away from a general election Euless
could play a driving role in the battle
for Downing Street Neve Barker Al
Jazeera London
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera